hello everyone and welcome to the
seventh annual Academy of Motion Picture
Arts and Sciences governor's Awards
we're delighted that you could join us
for this ceremony which is dedicated to
individuals whose careers have
transformed our industry and set a
standard of excellence admired around
the world I do feel it's important to
mention yesterday's horrifying attacks
in Paris and say that all of us here
stand in solidarity and support of
France and the French people
we may be in Hollywood tonight but the
Academy is an institution that
celebrates film wherever it is made our
connection with the film loving French
is especially deep with waves of
influence flowing back and forth across
the Atlantic
ever since the Lumiere brothers made the
first moving pictures so as we gather
here to celebrate our history and some
of the people who have made it we also
mourn those who died we send our deepest
affection to our brothers and sisters
and France before we turn the focus to
tonight's honorees I want to take this
opportunity to address an important
conversation which is going on in the
motion picture community and across the
country today it's a conversation about
recognizing and embracing a broad and
diverse cross-section of talent
something that I know all of you care
deeply about
I'm talking about diversity of age
gender race national origin and point of
view what Shonda Rhimes rightfully calls
the normalization of showbusiness a
process that needs to continue if we are
to faithfully represent the audience
which we serve you the people in this
room are the true movers and shakers of
our industry you understand that when it
comes to fair and equal representation
in our industry words are not enough we
also have a responsibility to take
action and we have a unique opportunity
to do so now interest in the motion
picture arts and sciences has never been
as strong as it is today the world is
watching to see how we respond to this
critical issue at the academy we want to
do our part to make this right this past
year we brought in a more diverse class
of new members than ever before this
incoming class of members doesn't just
include new talent but also includes
women and people of color and of varied
ethnicities who had been overlooked in
the past
in addition today 17 of our 51 governors
are women
but we want to do more than that we know
that the Academy is uniquely positioned
to take the lead on this issue to that
end we've started a new Academy
initiative a 2020 a five-year plan to
build on these efforts and to take
concrete measures to improve the
diversity of our staff and governance as
well as how we elect our leadership and
bring in new voices but we can't stop
there and we can't continue this effort
without your help this must truly be an
industry-wide commitment you have been
tremendous partners to the Academy since
our inception and in all our initiatives
to preserve the past honor the present
and shape the future of our industry we
ask you to partner with us again on this
critically important initiative many of
you our Academy members and as
ambassadors of our industry are in
positions of power to hire mentor
encourage and promote talent in all
areas of our profession I'm asking you
tonight directly to be our partners on
this critically important initiative
tonight we are honoring three
distinguished artists who represent both
Hollywood in its golden era an
independent cinema at its most cutting
edge and I'm pleased that this year two
of our honorees happen to be women and
one an african-american man Debbie
Reynolds Jenner Rollins and Spike Lee
follow very different
they follow very different trajectories
to preeminence but they are united by a
love of this art form you're going to
hear much more about them tonight from
their peers for now I want to simply
raise the glass to these three
remarkable artists and their exceptional
contributions to our profession okay
Cheers they are all an inspiration to us
all everyone stand please
to the three of you Debbie
Jenna and Spike thank you for your
outstanding bodies of work and the
legacies you have given us thank you
Cheers